cito testualmente lo studente e proietta
immagini inappropriate sulla lavagna
interattiva multimediale
solo che le immagini inappropriate con
sistema diventi cio che sono lanciato il
video in questione libica perché ha
fatto le cose seriamente
[Musica]
è un talento con un altro ma cosa ci
fossimo tutti a casa blog mas giorno 5
ciao a tutti bentornati una nuova
puntata di vita ha buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è note scolastiche per
la puntata di oggi ho pensato di
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia un ospite speciale un ospite
che farebbe di tutto pagherebbe
qualsiasi cifra pur di non essere
davanti alla mia webcam e non è una
webcam però non ha la mia videocamera
anche la botta ciao
vogliamo si sente io lo so che sei molto
in imbarazzo e lo sono anche per i
capelli
dovevano uscire rosso rosa e pio e lino
e vs perfetta per il tema perché sembri
molto
avril lavigne esatto sembra molto liceo
e al 19 veramente vestita così a roma io
no io adesso questi sì perché è una tale
no perché c'è un chiude capelli non c'è
il mio computer a qualche parte di tutto
questo quando non si fosse motivo
abbiamo alcun tempo di austin siamo il
pubblico abbiamo le risate finte al
pubblico amore
grazie mario che passa da boosta il mio
professore mi ha messo una nota perché
si era spaventato per un mio starnuto
detto che non solo perchè si pagano la
pubblica la porta in realtà non è
simpatica e quindi devo messo un
pubblico di sostegno bramato superiore
di un liceo artistico ora di plastica un
punto dietro ancora di plastica botto si
pretende l'ora di modellato lo facevo
anch'io e uno prendeva devo grinta cioè
io studiavo greco una lingua
incomprensibile alfabetico tifano cajun
ai voti raccordo plastiche i due anni ho
lavorato a un padre pio con altre in
realtà padre pio come me
ascoli sarebbe svanita casa letta
vabbè padre pio coi tacchi rb
riprendiamo da capo
ora di plastica e comparati classe
lancia dall'altra parte della classe non
è né argilla questo ed argilla ha
casualmente beccato la bacinella d'acqua
ea insudiciato altre quattro persone da
cui nota era nullo hicks lancia per
lancia per argilla e bagna quattro
persone
la paginata sarebbe stato in due secondi
io tanto viviamo possiamo 2000 cervo te
lo diamo no ciò che non sarebbe bastato
ma tu mi hai preso una nota più che la
bella presa alle medie per errore di
aver pianto per vigilare all'inizio di
mulan che portò edison avete note
ignorabili andava in una scuola solo di
fermine tranne un compagno maschio di
lottare anche l'unica cosa divertente
perché l'amico che prendeva le note ne
ha fatte di tutti i colori e non so se
si possono dire tipo attirato fuori
consilina livelli e melli dal aveva sul
tavolo la prof
facciamo spesso la tasca bucata e tipo
diceva riprendendo l'abatino di mani
sporche tipo ti faceva toccare pennello
nell'antico mania complice questa rabbia
46 tagliato le unghie dei piedi durante
la sezione a dicendo che era per un
progetto nardò si sta all'interno
dell'istituto dove siete tutte quante
ragazze non ci si può fidare a scuola o
la fidanzata squadra cioè mi aveva
portato a mangiare le sue l'italia mi ha
baciato abbiamo avuto in case solo un
anno che poi sono bocciofili era peggio
imbarcato loomis a cercare di tornare
all'asilo e questa nota scolastica non
riguarda me ma riguarda il mio ragazzo
che attualmente alto due metri 5 e con
tavares come padre pio
la mia ciao la mia nota peggiore è stata
ma porca li manda più lunghi di 4
secondi star
no quello sapere che cosa succede in 8
secondi di claudio non succede nulla
va bene come se ci dispiace comunque si
voleva far parte di quella volta nostre
stesse dicendo che libri fatti io così
scesa in terra per farti per le delghe
credo che le facesse solo supercazzole è
tra le sei stato abbastanza esaustivo
[Risate]
ciao scusa ciò è raffreddata mia
professoressa di matematica ha messo una
nota sul registro alla presidenza si
possono mettere nota oggetti col
bianchetto si sta comportando una
superiore a un certo punto ci ha fatto
sfilare in classe per vedere se
camminavamo bene ha detto a me io non so
che punto stiate comunque volevo dire
che ora ovviamente ho imparato a
camminare
siamo con lei lì c'è grande dai è
comunque meglio tardi che mai
fatemi vedere come camminate ragazzi
tutti i passanti si tocca e metteva i
voti tipo xfactor nel model basi sia una
cosa bella è che lei camminava bene così
così si cammina in realtà ragazzi e oggi
avete imparato qualcosa di nuovo prego
mia professoressa di italiano che era
una disse domani mi faccio una verifica
sorpresa ne abbiamo pregato in ogni modo
che gli succedesse qualcosa alla fine
se non l'hai fatto il giorno dopo non si
presenta ancora perché le scopriamo che
io ti voglio bene io non ti ho fatto
niente per chi voglia studia e non
c'entra niente non meno come detto
riguarda ha fatto benissimo ed è giusto
a scuola non bisogna fare verifiche non
bisogna studiare lotta non conosce
questo tipo di carichi leggera sua ex
che stava in macchina
lei diceva esci dalla mattina abbiamo
litigato dai un contesto che sono fa mi
aveva detto delle robe porti e se chiusi
in macchina allora io gli ho detto
scelti dalla macchina per parlarne
ovviamente come non voleva scendere dove
ha tirato fuori la chiave non scendi se
non scende ti scrivo figlio di comacchio
è arrivata per cui peso che vendo anche
letto ma perché era né pensato a tipo
solo perché è proprio la tav è così
maledetto villano e il mercante l'ora di
disegno un nostro compagno di classe si
alza dal nulla urla marlene ed è fuori
che tirano una mela che carino queste
sono bellissimi
siamo quelli che ci piacciono è una nota
comunque la creatività è e marlena torna
a casa con le altri gm lamela dice
spogliati voglia di nera se li costringe
la mela marlene indiana sera no no mio
compagno di classe aveva deciso di
portare con sé in una comunissima
giornata scolastica una bomboletta spray
questa bomboletta spray faceva puzza di
marcio di infettare tutta la nostra aula
è successivamente anche tutta la nostra
scuola
la nostra
per essa ha scritto sul registro oggi
non è possibile fare lezione perché la
scuola puzza di questa mamma se il
pulsare tutto questo per i corridoi da
me o si usava le nebbie cosa si chiamava
e centauro tiri prude era vecchia e
tutto quanto ma questa è ancora la prima
settimana adesso parlano il nemico
ricevuto una nota per aver rubato il
panino alla bidella per la nostra
professoressa è scritto sul diario cara
madre dell'alunno l è pregata di dar da
mangiare di più a suo figlio ma dotate
che la prossima volta
ruby nuovamente il pranzo la bidella e
carino si avvicini armio pamini l'hot e
rubo latitato stiamo facendo bene è il
vita buttata più lungo della storia nata
ma che vuol dire mai successo niente di
simile a una bidella all'improvviso il
bidello all'improvviso me lo immagino
che segue la un cespuglio come un
pokémon che nuova canzone
tra le persone di colpo vengono mandate
a fare le bidelle master b della della
falsa detroit per colpa di una mia
compagna di classe che faceva finta di
essere assatanata si prendeva la testa
con le mani da dietro questo come spiega
e faceva finta di tirarsela io limone
alle risate e quindi la professoressa mi
mandava sempre fuori dalla classe e io
mi mettevo a spazzare con i bidelli
italiani comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questa puntata vita buttata
io ringrazio avril ospite so anche se in
concerto interamente quindi si è molto
impegnata seguite le mie date del tour
spero con l'espace casa esattamente le
scritte ht così trasformato gatti
insieme all'oro al post reja va bene
ragazzi mi devono essere stata qui e
ringrazio anche il nostro pubblico
meraviglioso di amici e di persone che
sono più importanti dei miei amici
il di scultore di padre pio io come
sempre vi chiedo gentilmente di farmi
sapere naturalmente quali sono magari
delle idee che vi vengono riguardo dei
temi buttini buttati e rami buttati nel
futuro ripete anche nel aic se c'è
qualcuno che vi piace particolarmente
che leggete sotto in modo da far
risalire e familistico doveva andare a
mangiare contro non muoverci mica così
così con la piastra cappellino ci
vediamo attualmente giovedì prossimo con
una punta di vita puntata di domani con
il prossimo episodio del blog ma scavo
è
non ho l'età distribuzione